This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。在 Look Back at It 播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的伙伴以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听 Learn the Hard Way，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有牌照的专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？这向世界表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习 Learn the Hard Way。2023年，“钻石王老五”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健康和恢复力的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
也就是 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客任何地方的 TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s today. We are tackling the lucky last in our birth order series. You heard that right after all of the waiting and the many, many requests,
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，今天我们将一如既往地剖析我们20多岁时的心理。我们正在攻克出生顺序系列中的最后一个幸运儿。你没听过错，在所有的等待和许许多多的请求之后，
we are finally discussing the psychology of the youngest child. And what their position in the family means for everything from their personality to their relationship, and professional choices to their relationships with their middle and eldest siblings, not just in childhood, but in adulthood as well. The youngest child is quite obviously the baby of the family, and that position shapes their experiences a lot. And I'm so interested in the research around this, from birth order theory to some other theories,
我们终于要讨论老幺的心理了。他们在家庭中的地位意味着什么，从他们的性格、恋爱和职业选择，到他们与中间和最大兄弟姐妹的关系，不仅在童年时期，在成年时期也是如此。老幺很明显是家里最小的孩子，这种地位在很大程度上塑造了他们的经历。我对围绕这一主题的研究非常感兴趣，从出生顺序理论到其他一些理论，
as well of some of the stories that you all have shared with me. And, you know, we just have a really comprehensive, fascinating, packed personality episode for today. I don't do this very often, but I think I'm just going to skip the rest of this intro and let the episode speak for itself. You know, let's keep it short and sweet. There is so much to cover. Without further ado, let's discuss the psychology of the youngest child.
以及你们与我分享的一些故事。而且，你知道的，我们今天有一集内容非常全面、引人入胜且干货满满的性格特辑。我不经常这样做，但我想我还是跳过这段开场白的其余部分，让这一集本身说明问题吧。你知道的，长话短说。有太多内容要涵盖了。闲话少说，让我们来探讨老幺的心理。
So let's do a quick recap of what we know about birth order theory. So the arguments for it and the arguments against it. as well. We know that as humans, we are a product of many, many things, some tangible, some intangible, everything from genetics to country of birth to parenting style, food. All of these things, though, kind of fall into two categories, nature and nurture, what we are born with, what we are raised in. Now, the position we are born into a family is part of our environment. And therefore, it kind of falls into the nurture category. It influences our personality because of how it impacts how we were raised and therefore how we end up experiencing the world into adulthood. So the saying really goes and I always use
那么让我们快速回顾一下我们对出生顺序理论的了解。也就是支持它的论点和反对它的论点。我们知道，作为人类，我们是许多许多因素的产物，有些是有形的，有些是无形的，从基因到出生国家、育儿风格、食物，应有尽有。然而，所有这些东西大致可以分为两类：先天和后天，即我们天生具有的，以及我们成长于其中的环境。现在，我们出生在家庭中的地位是我们环境的一部分。因此，它基本上属于后天因素的范畴。它通过影响我们的养育方式，进而影响我们成年后体验世界的方式，从而对我们的性格产生影响。所以俗话说得好，我也总是用
the saying to describe birth order theory. Just because you are raised in the same house doesn't mean that you had the same childhood as your siblings. And your position in the family contributes to this difference in childhoods. Because, you know, for all intents and purposes, two people who go through the same upbringing and are raised in the same house by the same parents, they should turn out pretty similar. And yes, we have to account for nature and our personality and how we're just born and who we are when we kind of come out of the womb. But there is a significant difference in how our parents treat us. So the man who developed birth order theory, he was kind of the first one to say to notice this. His name was Alfred Adler. You may also know him from the creation of the
这句话来形容出生顺序理论。并不是说你在同一个家里长大，就意味着你和你的兄弟姐妹有着相同的童年。而你在家庭中的地位正是造成这种童年差异的原因。因为，无论出于什么目的，两个经历相同抚养长大、在同一个家里由同一对父母养大的人，他们应该变得非常相似。是的，我们必须考虑先天因素和我们的性格，以及我们刚出生时天生是谁。但是，我们的父母对待我们的方式存在着显著的差异。因此，提出出生顺序理论的那个人，他是第一个注意到这一点的人。他的名字叫阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒。你可能也从他创立的
inferiority complex. Also, he was like a founding father of individual psychology, which if you study psychology, you've probably done like, I don't know, a unit in this. Basically, he says that in individual psychology, what we're really looking for is a sense of mastery and a sense of completeness. That doesn't really matter. It's not what we're talking about today. But he was really working hard during, you know, the early and mid-1900s. But birth order theory, as it stands today, is probably what he is most well known for. And it basically says that being the oldest, youngest, middle, or only child will affect what characteristics and traits you develop. Now, let's be really, really clear because I see a lot of like birth order theory TikToks going around and Instagram videos.
自卑情结中知道他。此外，他是个体心理学的奠基人之一，如果你学过心理学，你可能做过，我不知道，这方面的一个单元。基本上，他说在个体心理学中，我们真正寻找的是一种掌控感和完整感。其实这并不重要。这不是我们今天要谈论的。但他在20世纪初和中期确实付出了很多努力。不过，就目前的出生顺序理论而言，这可能是他最著名的成就。它基本上指出，作为老大、老幺、老二或独生子女，会影响你形成哪些性格特征。现在，让我们非常非常明确这一点，因为我看到很多关于出生顺序理论的 TikTok 视频和 Instagram 视频。
it is not a medical prescription. Like I cannot diagnose you as an eldest daughter. I cannot diagnose you as a youngest son. Like that's a descriptor. It doesn't, you know, if you go to a psychologist, they're not going to like include that on your chart notes as like something that needs an intervention. Because it's just kind of who you are.
它不是一张医学处方。就像我不能诊断你为大女儿一样。我不能诊断你为小儿子。这只是一个描述性的词。它并不能，你知道的，如果你去看心理医生，他们不会把这个写在你的病历上，当作需要干预的事情。因为这只是你的本性。
It's definitely like a theory. It's a theory and a theory like any theory like has gaps. It has exceptions. It has flaws. what I kind of see birth order theory is doing is filling the same role as personality tests. Like they provide, like there is research behind them and they provide a structural guide for better understanding of where we sit in relation to others, but they are not a full answer to the questions we have about ourselves. Like they're really interesting to explore and they're really interesting for reflection.
这绝对是一个理论。它是一个理论，而任何理论都像任何理论一样存在漏洞。它有例外，有缺陷。在我看来，出生顺序理论的作用和性格测试差不多。它们提供了——也就是说，它们背后有研究支撑，并且它们提供了一个结构化的指南，帮助我们更好地理解我们在与他人关系中的位置，但它们并不是我们关于自身的疑问的完整答案。就像它们非常有趣，值得探索，也很适合反思。
But of course, anything like that that says you are only the way you are because of this. one thing and this one test or this one theory can tell you like it's not accurate we exist in a much larger ecosystem of factors and contexts and situations with that being said let's say what this theory has to say about the unique traits and character of the youngest child according to this theory the eldest child is often very responsible very type a they kind of take care of everyone else especially if you're an eldest daughter you know that kind of makes sense they matured are the fastest, they're the eldest. They take care of a lot of the younger children. They're set up as a role model. Then we have the middle child. The middle child is seen as the mediator or the
但是，当然，任何类似这样的说法，如果你之所以成为现在的你，全是因为这一个因素、这一个测试或这一个理论所能告诉你的，那并不准确。我们生活在更加庞大的因素、背景和情境生态系统中。话虽如此，让我们来看看这个理论对老幺独特性格和特征的看法。根据这个理论，老大通常非常负责，属于非常典型的 A 型人格，他们有点照顾其他所有人，特别是如果你是大女儿，你知道，这有点道理，他们成熟得最快，因为他们是老大。他们照顾很多年幼的孩子。他们被树立为榜样。然后我们有老二。老二被视为调解者或
peacemaker. They're actually sometimes referred to as the easy or invisible child because of how they are sandwiched between the eldest and the youngest. Also, middle children, like sometimes they don't even get to be the only middle child. Like they have to share that position with someone else. And then we have the youngest child, the little baby of the family. By the time your parents have gotten to their final child, especially if you're in a big family of three plus kids, like let's be so real. They are tired.
调解者。有时他们甚至被称为“轻松的孩子”或“隐形的孩子”，因为他们夹在老大和老小中间。而且，中间的孩子有时甚至无法成为唯一的中间孩子。他们必须与其他人分享这个位置。然后我们有了最小的孩子，家里的宝贝。当你父母生到最小的孩子时，特别是如果你在一个有三个或更多孩子的大家庭里，让我们面对现实吧。他们已经累了。
They are tired. All of the discipline that they had for their eldest or older children, all the rules that they promised to implement, all their energy has kind of dissipated because parenting is really, really hard. It reminds me of this interview I saw the other day with Billy Eilish's mom, really random. And she talked about how being a parent, especially being a mother, requires you to use every single creative skill, every single life skill you have ever developed. Like anything you would put on a resume and more goes into being a parent. And it's right.
他们累了。他们对老大或大一点的那些孩子的所有纪律，他们承诺要实施的所有规则，他们所有的精力基本上都消散了，因为养育孩子真的是太难太难了。这让我想起了前几天我看到的一个关于比利·艾利什（Billie Eilish）妈妈的采访，非常随机。她谈到为人父母，特别是当母亲，需要你运用你开发过的每一项创造力技能、每一项生活技能。就像你在简历上会写的东西以及更多，都投入到了育儿中。这是对的。
Like she's totally right. It's a full time, full soul, full body effort. And imagine giving 100% to your. job for 18 years straight, like by the time you get to that final kid, those final years, like you are cutting a few corners, especially when they're teenagers as well. So there's a 2008 study that looked into this conducted by researches at Duke University. And if you want to check out this research paper, it's titled The Games, Parents and Adolescents Play. And what they found was that eldest and older siblings are actually raised in a more strict environment.
和平缔造者。他们有时甚至被称为轻松或隐形的孩子，因为他们夹在老大和老幺之间。此外，老二，有时候他们甚至都不能独占老二的位置。他们必须和别人分享这个位置。然后我们有老幺，家里的小宝贝。当你的父母生下他们的最后一个孩子时，特别是如果你在一个有三个或更多孩子的大家庭里，让我们现实一点。他们累了。
like they're penalized more. Sometimes they're used as an example, but it also does seem that our parents get softer with age. As a result, youngest children, they kind of sense they know that they can get away with much more than their eldest or older brothers, siblings, sisters. So they're on average more likely to engage in risky behaviours. Research from the University of Birmingham and the University of Reading.
比如他们受到的惩罚更多。有时他们被当作榜样，但也确实看起来我们的父母随着年龄增长变得更温和了。因此，最小的孩子有一种直觉，他们知道自己比老大或年长的兄弟姐妹、姐姐能逃脱更多的惩罚。因此，他们平均而言更有可能从事冒险行为。伯明翰大学和雷丁大学的研究表明，
I don't know if it's Reading or reading. I'm going to say Reading. They also found that youngest children, in the families. They are also more likely to be self-employed. They are nearly 50% more likely to take the risk of going into business for themselves. So they're risk-takers, they're entrepreneurial. And these findings were like, this was a large study.
我不知道是读 Reading 还是别的，我姑且读作雷丁。他们还发现，家庭中最小的孩子也更有可能自己创业。他们进行自主创业的概率高出近 50%。所以他们是冒险家，具有创业精神。这些发现非常重要，这是一项大规模的研究。
It had almost 17,000 children who they surveyed them first in 1970. And then again, at 38 years old. And some of them are younger, some of them are middle, some of them were only children. and the youngest child, they were the ones who are most likely to take risks. I think that's a really cool trait about younger siblings. And I will say the people who I know in my life who have taken the leap of faith to start their own business to take the road less traveled, like the majority of them are younger siblings.
他们调查了近 17,000 名儿童，第一次是在 1970 年，然后在他们 38 岁时再次进行调查。其中一些是老小，一些是中间的，一些是独生子女。而最小的孩子，他们是最有可能冒险的人。我认为这是年幼的兄弟姐妹身上一个非常酷的特质。我想说，我生活中认识的那些勇敢迈出这一步去创业、走少有人走的路的人，绝大多数都是年幼的兄弟姐妹。
And I think about like my office space. So I work in an office space that I kind of rent out with a couple of friends in Sydney. and most of them like are running their own businesses, they're running their own side hustles and like they're doing that full time or they're self like they're self contracted like they do contract jobs and every single one of them that's in that office is a youngest child. So speaking of entrepreneurial spirit like that's the evidence I kind of see in my own life which is obviously speculation but I think it's interesting. I will say please by no means take any of these.
我想到了我的办公空间。我在悉尼和一个朋友合租了一个办公空间，他们大多数人都在经营自己的生意，经营自己的副业，并且全职做这些，或者他们是自由签约的，比如他们做合同工。那个办公室里的每一个人都是老小。所以说到创业精神，这就是我在自己生活中看到的证据，这显然只是推测，但我认为这很有趣。请大家千万不要把这些
observations as rules. Like, if you are a youngest child and you're not entrepreneurial, it doesn't mean that there's something wrong with you. Or if you're listening to this and you're not a youngest child, like, and you want to start a business, like, by no means does this mean that you can't? Like, it's, it's, I think, ridiculous to look at these rules and think that they will apply to everyone. But I think it's just an interesting pattern to recognize in society amongst people who are
观察结果当作绝对的规则。如果你是一个老小但没有创业精神，并不意味着你有什么问题。或者如果你在听这个节目，你不是老小，但你想创业，这绝不意味着你不能这样做。看着这些规则并认为它们适用于所有人，我认为这太荒谬了。但我认为这只是社会中人们做出的一种有趣的模式，人们
just making organic choices. This really links to the first big stereotype about youngest children, though, that they're rebellious, that they're more carefree. You know, the youngest child is sometimes seen as the problem child. Like, they're the ones who need to, like, get bailed out of jail or whatever, because they seem to have had a more relaxed childhood environment. And what also comes with this relaxed environment is being spoiled. So the second big stereotype for today is that youngest children are spoiled. they get more gifts, they get more financial support, they get more praise. There is much less research on this compared to the previous stereotype, mainly because it's
只是在做自然的抉择。这确实与关于老小的第一个大刻板印象联系在一起，那就是他们叛逆，更加无忧无虑。你知道，老小有时被视为问题儿童。比如，他们是那些需要被保释出狱之类的人，因为他们似乎拥有更放松的童年环境。伴随这种放松环境而来的还有被溺爱。所以今天的第二个大刻板印象是老小被溺爱。他们得到更多礼物，更多经济支持，更多赞扬。与之前的刻板印象相比，这方面的研究要少得多，主要是因为它
slightly hard to measure because of what we call the social desirability bias in psychological research. So if we ask parents, okay, which one of your kids gets more gifts? Which kid do you spend more money on, etc? they obviously don't want to sound like they're playing favourites so they're not going to be entirely honest and if you ask the youngest child they're probably not going to have noticed right there may be a situation where when you're asking them like they're probably over the age of 18 in order to participate in this research like they're probably the only child left at home if that's the case so they don't have the comparison that the eldest and middle children would have and that's the final person we might ask
在心理学研究中，由于我们所说的社会称许性偏差，这有点难以衡量。因此，如果我们问父母，好吧，你们哪个孩子得到的礼物更多？你们在哪个孩子身上花的钱更多，等等？他们显然不想让自己听起来像是在偏心，所以他们不会完全诚实。如果你问老小，他们可能不会注意到这一点。当你问他们时，他们可能已经年满 18 岁才能参与这项研究，如果真是这样，他们可能是家里唯一剩下的孩子，所以他们没有老大和中间的孩子所拥有的比较对象，而这正是我们可能会问的最后一个人群。
eldest and middle children. They probably are also going to be biased. You know how like competitive siblings can get. You know, they might be looking at the youngest child, the youngest baby of the family and going like, hey, I never got that. Like I never got to buy new shoes whenever I wanted. Like I never got to just get away with things like that. So it's a kind of a tricky one to think about. Like if you find a way to measure this, please let me know. I think it would be a very interesting study. But basically what we can really rely on is kind of speculation and it's speculation that I want you to, I want you to do for yourself. So I'm going to give you a hypothetical and you just tell me if this applies to you. So thinking about your family, Christmases, holidays, celebrations, which child got more presents,
老大和中间的孩子。他们可能也会带有偏见。你知道兄弟姐妹之间的竞争有多激烈。他们可能会看着最小的孩子、家里的宝贝说，嘿，我从来没有得到过那些。我从没有想买新鞋就能买。我从没有像那样逃脱过惩罚。所以这是一个有点棘手的问题。如果你能找到方法来衡量这一点，请告诉我。我认为这将是一个非常有趣的研究。但基本上我们真正能依靠的是推测，而且这种推测是我希望你为自己做的。所以我将给你一个假设，你只要告诉我这是否适用于你。想想你的家庭、圣诞节、假期、庆祝活动，哪个孩子得到了更多礼物，
got more attention, got more time, maybe got more financial help, whatever it is, like money. It is usually the youngest. And you know what? Quite. frankly, I understand. Like, they're the cutest. Everyone likes the little one. Everyone feels more protective of the youngest because they are by their age, less capable, less mature. So, naturally, it might seem that they're being spoiled in comparison to older siblings at the time. But when the eldest child was also at the younger stage, like at some point the eldest child is going to be an only child, they were probably also spoiled to the same degree. In fact, I think it's actually the middle child who tends to miss out the most. Also, like it's not all sunshine and
得到了更多关注，更多时间，也许得到了更多经济帮助，无论是什麽，比如金钱。通常都是老小。你知道吗？说实话，我理解。因为他们最可爱。每个人都喜欢小家伙。每个人对老小都更有保护欲，因为按他们的年龄来看，他们能力更强、更不成熟。因此，自然而然地，与当时的年长兄弟姐妹相比，他们似乎被宠坏了。但当老大也处于较小阶段时，在某个时候老大也曾是独生子女，他们可能也受到了同样的宠爱。事实上，我认为往往是中间的孩子感觉被冷落得最多。而且，生活对老小来说也并非全是阳光和
rainbows for the youngest. Like this pattern of behavior of being spoiled of maybe being, people being less strict with them can also lead to a phenomenon known as infantilization. This is something that youngest children, you know, report that they experience. Even when they leave their childhood and their teenage years, even when they become adults, they are still treated like an infant. They are still treated as less capable by their families because even when they're 20, 25, 30, 50, their age may change, but the position in the family as the youngest doesn't change. And this can be a big source of tension for some people as they get older and they try and advocate for themselves. They try and be independent. They try and, you know, take charge in
彩虹。这种被宠爱、人们对他们不那么严格的行为模式，也可能导致一种被称为“幼儿化”的现象。这是老小们报告说他们经历过的事情。即使他们离开童年和青少年时期，即使他们成为成年人，他们仍然像幼儿一样被对待。他们仍然被家人视为缺乏能力的人，因为即使他们 20 岁、25 岁、30 岁、50 岁，他们的年龄可能会变，但他们在家庭中作为老小的地位没有变。对于一些人在年龄增长、试图为自己发声、试图独立、试图在
the family. Sometimes they are met with resistance. So there was a large, scale internet study published in 2022 that looked at over 32,000 individuals and it found that this treatment, this infantilization actually was really, really harmful and led to a lot of resentment, but also led to a lack of confidence sometimes, specifically amongst people who were youngest children or who had reported experiencing it, not just in childhood, but now as adults. Okay, so let's talk about one more aspect or a stereotype of the youngest child personality that you may have already heard of. So we talked about how they are risk takers, a bit rebellious, how they may be spoiled.
家庭中掌控局面时，这可能会成为紧张的重要来源。有时他们会遭到抵制。因此，2022 年发表了一项大规模的互联网研究，调查了超过 32,000 名个人，发现这种对待方式、这种幼儿化实际上非常非常有害，并导致了许多怨恨，有时还导致缺乏自信，特别是对于那些是老小或报告曾经历过这种对待的人来说，不仅在童年时期，在现在的成年时期也是如此。好了，让我们来谈谈你可能已经听说过的老小性格的另一个方面或刻板印象。我们讨论了他们如何爱冒险、有点叛逆，以及他们如何被宠坏。
You've probably also heard that they're, you know, their attention seekers. They like to make waves. They like to stir the pot. They like to put on the dance shows to be a bit ridiculous. I personally think this is also what makes them so social and really charming. You know, the reason why this may be the case is because the youngest child has had to battle to be noticed. You know, yes, they may be spoiled, but they are also sometimes the second, third, fourth, maybe even fifth child. Everyone else has kind of already found their role.
你可能也听说过他们是寻求关注的人。他们喜欢兴风作浪。他们喜欢挑起事端。他们喜欢表演舞蹈，表现得有点荒谬。我个人认为，这也是他们如此善于社交和极具魅力的原因。这种情况之所以存在，可能是因为老小不得不争取被注意到。是的，他们可能被宠坏了，但他们有时也是第二个、第三个、第四个，甚至第五个孩子。其他人已经找到了自己的角色。
You know, the family may be at max capacity. So the youngest wants to find their space. They want to find their part. And that can lead to what we would call attention, behavior. But I think it's, you know, deeper than that. I think it's actually identity formation when you have someone who has already set the bar, when you have the eldest children. Also, just to throw this stereotype even further out the window, some research actually suggests that it's actually eldest or only children who typically want or demand more attention because they, you know,
你知道，家庭可能已经达到最大容量。所以老小想要找到自己的空间。他们想找到自己的位置。这可能会导致我们所说的寻求关注的行为。但我认为这比这更深刻。我认为这实际上是身份的形成，当你有一个已经设定了标准的人，当你有了年长的孩子。另外，为了彻底推翻这个刻板印象，一些研究实际上表明，通常是老大或独生子女才真正想要或要求更多的关注，因为他们，
they remember a time when they got it all. So I don't think that this like, stereotype is entirely true. There you go. We debunked some of the common misconceptions about youngest children, but also kind of hopefully confirmed some of their wonderful traits, which is that they're fun, they're outgoing, they're entrepreneurial, their risk takers. We are going to take a short break, but when we return, we are going to talk about whether being a youngest child has, you know, any impact on dating choices, career choices. and how to deal with some of the downsides of being the last born. So stay with us.
他们还记得曾经拥有一切的时光。所以我不认为这个刻板印象完全正确。就是这样。我们揭穿了一些关于老小的常见误解，但也希望证实了他们的一些优秀特质，即他们很有趣、外向、有创业精神、爱冒险。我们将稍作休息，但回来后，我们将讨论作为老小是否对约会选择、职业选择有任何影响，以及如何应对作为老幺的一些负面影响。所以请继续收听。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等对话，看穿那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症吗？
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Cent on the I-E-Rashire. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力造成的。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听 2%。也就是 IHeart 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO-PCent。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什和金伯莉到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在 Look Back at It 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格里斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。包括最近一集马克兰蒙特希尔大谈 80 年代霹雳娇娃的节目。需要明确的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为毒品。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以谈论当天的毒品，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论毒品的第二集，所以我开始看到一条主线了。我们现在也有艾滋病在讨论范围内，所以……谢谢你完成这句话。是的，我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在 IHeart 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学习》，我是你的主持人，你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
而我们还在追逐它，并且不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们在看记分牌，生活变成了胜负。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。
Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct?
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023 年，前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，桑兹女士，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespean. My mind was blown.
我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯平。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IHeart 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never. mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
每个男人都应该遵循两个黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，千万不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女友们》中……哦，天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，所以他们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he did. serves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. A big element of birth order theory that I think fascinates people to no end is how it can potentially influence some rather big choices and aspects of our life, from who we choose to date, who we choose to marry, who we choose to be friends with, to profession even and so much
他将得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 IHeart 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。出生顺序理论的一个重要元素，我认为它让人着迷不已，那就是它如何潜在地影响我们生活中的一些重大选择和方面，从我们选择和谁约会、和谁结婚、和谁交朋友，到职业甚至更多。
more. So does being the youngest child predict much when it comes to these large choices? Let's start by talking about relationships. The biggest thing you will hear when it comes to dating choices for youngest children is that they will only choose an older sibling, like a firstborn or an older middle child because they tend to appreciate the stability. They want that rock. They want someone to calm their wildness maybe. And for their partner, who is an eldest child or an older child, they are very responsible so they appreciate the spontaneity. They like to be with someone who can help them see things differently and kind of let loose. That's particularly the case, you know, some people would suggest for younger sons who are heterosexual, they may be more inclined
那么，作为老小能否在这些重大选择方面预测什么呢？让我们从关系开始谈起。说到老小的约会选择，你会听到最大的一点是，他们只会选择年长的兄弟姐妹，比如头胎或较大的中间孩子，因为他们往往欣赏稳定性。他们想要那种依靠。他们可能想要有人来平息他们的野性。而对于他们的伴侣来说，作为老大或较大的孩子，他们非常负责，所以他们欣赏自发性。他们喜欢和一个能帮他们换个角度看问题、有点放得开的人在一起。特别是对于异性恋的年幼儿子来说，有人会建议他们可能更倾向于
to date eldest daughters. Now, let me say this. This has, absolutely been the case of my own life. Like my boyfriend of almost two years, he is a younger son. All of my best friends who are eldest daughters are dating younger sons. And this is why I find it so rewarding. My boyfriend is just so chill. Like he is so chill. No drama. All fun, all outgoing, clear-headed. And for someone who is quite anxious, who really overthinks everything, who is perfectionist and I feel like I need to be in control. He really levels me out in like the perfect complimentary way. It's like, you know, how they say opposites attract. Like we fill the parts of the other person's personality that they can't feel themselves. And I really feel like that has been
和长女约会。现在，让我这么说。这绝对是我自己生活的情况。比如我交往了近两年的男朋友，他是一个年幼的儿子。我所有的长女闺蜜都在和年幼的儿子约会。这就是为什么我发现这如此有益。我的男朋友太冷静了。他太冷静了。没有抓马。充满乐趣、外向、头脑清晰。对于一个相当焦虑、对每件事都过度思考、是个完美主义者并且觉得自己需要掌控一切的人来说，他真的以一种完美互补的方式让我平静下来。就像人们说的异性相吸。我们填补了彼此性格中无法自行填补的部分，我真的觉得这就是。
the case. And obviously it's not just birth order theory. It's a lot of other factors that have contributed to us being together. But, you know, like he has older sisters. So that probably also helped. But, you know, when I hear this idea of like eldest daughters, younger sons, I'm always like, oh, I hate to say it, but it applies. Only children and lastborns. So only children and youngest children also balance each other out really, really well for some reason. So I heard this really fascinating interview with this psychologist,
这只是其中一个情况。显然，不仅仅是出生顺序理论，还有很多其他因素促成了我们在一起。但是，你知道的，比如他有姐姐，所以这可能也有所帮助。不过，每当我听到老大配老幺这种说法时，我总是会想，哦，我真不想承认，但它确实适用。独生子女和老幺。所以独生子女和最小的孩子由于某种原因也能非常非常完美地互补。所以我听过一个非常有趣的采访，采访了一位心理学家，
and she was talking about why this is the case. And she said, it really has to do with the fact that, firstborns and only children are kind of cut from the same cloth. So if you're a youngest child and you like eldest children, like that's who you kind of end up dating a lot of, only children are very, very similar. They're very self-reliant. They're expected to succeed.
她谈到了为什么会这样。她说，这实际上与以下事实有关：老大和独生子女本质上是一类人。所以如果你是老幺，而你喜欢老大，那你最后约会的人往往也都是这种类型，独生子女非常非常相似。他们非常独立，被寄予厚望。之所会这样，
And then you have the younger child who brings like the liveliness and the creativity to the relationship. So again, it helps, they counteracts in a really specific way. So I think whilst, you know, younger siblings are very much risk takers. They're entrepreneurial. Sometimes they also kind of fly by the seat of their pants. That kind of makes it chaotic if two youngest siblings are dating because someone needs to be, have that kind of organizational part of their brain at the forefront.
然后你会发现最小的孩子给这段关系带来了活力和创造力。所以同样地，它在某种程度上起到了非常具体的平衡作用。因此我认为，虽然年幼的兄弟姐妹非常喜欢冒险，他们很有创业精神，有时他们也喜欢凭感觉行事。如果两个老幺在谈恋爱，这种性格就会变得很混乱，因为总得有人来担当那种具有组织能力的角色。
Like someone needs to be somewhat forward thinking, somewhat responsible. And if you have like two youngest siblings together, yeah, it can be exploits. like you're both risk takers, you're both outgoing, but sometimes you need like that anchor. So that is what birth order theory and position might mean for dating. Again, this is no, like this is not a restrictive rule. If you can find someone that you love and you care about, like doesn't matter, doesn't matter where they were born, who they were, like, what position in the family. Like, that kind of love is rare enough.
就像总得有人有点前瞻性，有点责任感。如果你有两个老幺在一起，是的，那可能会引发状况。就像你们俩都喜欢冒险，你们俩都很外向，但有时你们需要那种精神支柱。这就是出生顺序理论和排位对约会可能意味着的东西。再说一次，这并不是一条限制性的规则。如果你能找到一个你爱的人，一个你在乎的人，这真的没关系，不管他们出生在哪里，不管他们是谁，不管他们在家庭里排行老几。这种爱已经够难得了。
So don't listen to this and look at your own life and say, oh my God, I'm dating. a youngest child. And I am a youngest child. Like, we should break up. No, please don't do that. Please don't do that because of me because it's like, it's one of many, many things. So we've already spoken about how youngest children take more risks. So that makes them, you know, business leaders, startup founders, quite entrepreneurial. But really, there haven't been any long-term studies on birth order and career prospects, which, I don't know, I think that that would be. I would be really phenomenal for all like the somewhat controversy around birth order theory. I feel like a study like that could really maybe silence or prove some of the doubts and it
所以不要听了这些就审视自己的生活然后说，天哪，我正在和老幺约会，而我偏偏也是个老幺，我们应该分手。不，请不要这样做。请千万不要因为我的一番话而分手，因为这只是众多因素中的一个。我们之前已经讨论过最小的孩子如何承担更多的风险。这使得他们成为了商业领袖、初创公司创始人，相当具有创业精神。但实际上，目前还没有关于出生顺序和职业前景的长期研究，我不知道，我认为那将是非常棒的。对于所有围绕出生顺序理论的争议来说，我觉得这样的一项研究或许真的能平息或证实一些疑虑，而且
would be so fascinating to do like a longitudinal research study where you interview like people at 12 at 19 and then at 30 or some point in time and see what careers they ended up choosing. But looking at our profile again of youngest children, they're outgoing social, rule changes charming maybe a little bit attention seeking even those negative qualities are assets the assets when it comes to your career someone with these traits is more likely to thrive in a profession that involves performance leadership persuasion risk taking so things like entertainment sales being a startup founder investment banking an investigative journalist a lobbyist like someone who really pushes bounds, someone who isn't afraid to be, you know, perhaps a little bit more out there
进行一项纵向研究会非常迷人，比如在人们12岁、19岁和30岁或某个时间点对他们进行采访，看看他们最终选择了什么职业。但再来看看我们对老幺的画像，他们外向、社交、喜欢打破规则、迷人，甚至可能有点爱出风头，即使是这些负面特质，在你的职业生涯中也会变成优势。拥有这些特质的人更有可能在涉及表演、领导力、说服力、冒险的行业中大放异彩。比如娱乐、销售、初创公司创始人、投资银行、调查记者、游说者，也就是那种真正敢于打破常规、不怕表现得更张扬一点的人。
than your average Joe. I think about my youngest sister as an example of this all the time. Like, she is so creative, but she also thinks and dreams so much bigger than me. You know, I am very overly cautious. My middle sister is just like the chillest person ever. Like she's an athlete, so she's very focused. But she's also just like, yeah, whatever, I'm going to go with the flow, whatever happens will happen. My little sister, though, is like, I am going to conquer the world. And I'm always the one who's like, oh my God, but have you considered this? Like, this could go wrong. Like, have you considered this?
比一般人要强。我总是想到我的小妹作为这个例子的。比如说，她非常有创意，但她的思考和梦想也比我宏大得多。你知道，我非常过于谨慎。我的二姐简直是世界上最随性的人。她是个运动员，所以她非常专注。但她也觉得，随波逐流就好，船到桥头自然直。不过我的小妹却总是说，我要征服世界。而我总是那个说，哦天哪，但你考虑过这个吗？这可能会出问题。比如，你考虑过这个吗？
Like, this could be a problem. Like, what are you going to do about that? And she's kind of like, okay, I'll deal with it. Like, she really has that vibe of like, it's going to work out for me. And it's something I really, really love about her. The youngest child definitely has their, you know, with all their strengths, there's also things they struggle. with in relation to like the family dynamic and we've talked about them a little bit already but one we haven't spoken about is like a sense of competition and feeling left out by their other siblings so especially when you're a child like you forever want to be part of the big kids games and the big kids activities but you know you're just the little you're the little annoying one you're the one that's
比如，这可能会是个问题。你打算怎么处理？而她大概会觉得，好吧，我会处理的。她真的有一种一切都会顺利解决的气场。这是我非常非常喜欢她的一点。最小的孩子肯定有他们的，你知道的，在他们所有的优点背后，也有他们在家庭动态中挣扎的地方，我们之前已经讨论过一些了，但有一个我们还没谈过，那就是竞争感和被其他兄弟姐妹冷落的感觉。所以尤其是当你还是个孩子的时候，你永远都想加入大孩子的游戏和大孩子的活动，但你知道你只是个小不点，你是那个烦人的家伙，你是那个
like going to ruin it. You're like not quite at the level that your oldest siblings want you to be at. And it can mean that you feel, you know, quite excluded and quite like almost in competition with yourself to get an invite to this like exclusive childhood party. I think they sometimes feel looked down upon. You can feel really compared to your older sibling or overshadowed. not because you're less capable, just because you've simply had less time. Like, having older siblings is like having a moving marker ahead of you that is impossible to reach. Like, even if you do somehow reach it, like, there's always going to be, you know,
可能会搞砸一切的人。你还没达到你大哥哥大姐姐们希望你达到的水平。这意味着你可能会感到相当被排斥，甚至有点在和自己竞争，为了获得这个专属童年派对的邀请函。我觉得他们有时会觉得自己被看不起。你会觉得真的会和你的大哥哥大姐姐进行比较，或者被他们的光芒掩盖。不是因为你能力不足，只是因为你花的时间确实更少。拥有年长的兄弟姐妹就像前面有一个移动的标记，是你永远无法追赶上的。就像，即使你不知怎么追上了，你知道，
you're always going to be looking back and seeing what the elder sibling is doing. And there is a sense of competition. Like, they were the first one to graduate high school. They may have been the first one to go to university, the first one to do. all of these things that you can only just do after them. And if you are perhaps not as intelligent or academically inclined as they are, can feel like your parents or your aunts or your uncles or people are looking at you and being like, oh, like you're their sibling.
你总是会回头看，看看年长的兄弟姐妹在做什么。而且确实有一种竞争感。比如，他们是第一个高中毕业的。他们可能是第一个上大学的，第一个做所有这些你只能在他们之后才能做的事情的人。如果你可能没有他们那么聪明或有学术头脑，就会觉得你的父母、你的阿姨、你的叔叔或者其他人看着你，然后说，哦，你是他们的兄弟姐妹。
How come you're not operating at their level? I have found, though, that actually this tends to switch up the older we get. So the sense of competition and comparison, and kind of goes away. And I was talking to my friend Steph about this and how she has an older sister. And her older sister was like, well, now I compare myself to you. Like you are doing such cool things. And as I'm like approaching 30, like, I kind of want your life.
怎么你没有达到他们的水平？不过我发现，其实随着我们年龄增长，这种情况往往会发生转变。所以这种竞争感和比较感，某种程度上就消失了。我和我的朋友斯蒂夫谈过这件事，她有一个姐姐。她的姐姐说，嗯，现在我和你作比较了。你正在做这么酷的事情。当我也快30岁的时候，我有点想要你的生活。
And I was like, huh, that's very, very interesting that you spend your whole childhood wanting to be like your elder siblings. And then, you know, your eldest sibling looks back and is like, I just want to be where you are. Like I'm so nostalgic, but also so impressed by you. Final point, and this was wonderfully described by an article from the therapeutic Center for Anxiety and Trauma, and it's that youngest children struggle with just getting whatever's leftover. And I don't just mean food or resources or even hand-me-downs. I'm talking about roles in the family. The longer a family has been together, the more rigid every person's role has become.
我当时想，哇，这真的非常非常有趣，你整个童年都想成为年长的兄弟姐妹那样的人。然后，你知道，年长的兄弟姐妹回过头来看，却说，我只想成为你那样。我太怀念了，但也对你印象深刻。最后一点，这被治疗焦虑与创伤治疗中心的一篇文章完美地描述了，那就是最小的孩子往往只能得到剩下的东西。我指的不仅仅是食物、资源甚至二手衣物。我说的是在家庭中的角色。一个家庭在一起的时间越长，每个人的角色就越僵化。
come. So by the time the younger sibling arrives, the family has kind of established a pretty consistent and fixed dynamic that more or less works for everyone involved. So younger siblings may end up adopting whatever role the family still needs and still lacks. So if everyone in the family is happy go lucky and really go with the flow, the younger sibling might, you know, fill that gap and become the responsible one. or another scenario, you know, everyone in the family is arguing and fighting and there's a lot of tension. The youngest sibling may feel inclined to break the tension by being the joker or by redirecting the focus of the family onto themselves. Also an interesting phenomena that I think
来。所以当小弟弟或小妹妹到来时，家庭已经建立了一种相当一致且固定的动态，对涉及到的每个人来说或多或少都行得通。所以较小的兄弟姐妹最终可能会扮演家庭仍然需要和缺乏的角色。所以如果家里的每个人都无忧无虑且非常随性，年幼的弟弟妹妹可能会，你知道，填补那个空白，成为负责任的那个人。或者另一种情况，你知道，家里的每个人都在争吵，气氛非常紧张。最小的弟弟妹妹可能会觉得有必要通过成为开心果或将家庭的注意力转移到自己身上来打破这种紧张。还有一个有趣的现象，我认为
we're noticing maybe more these days is youngest children who have a significant age gap between themselves and the next child up. So people who, you know, their parents were kind of done having kids pretty early and then they were surprised by another baby or they decided, you know, a little bit later like, okay, it doesn't feel like our family is quite complete. Like it feels like we're missing someone and they choose to have a child much, much later on. And in that case, like the youngest child can take on the personality of an only child because it, you know, I I've heard of age gaps of like 15, 20 years at times. Like that's possible these days.
我们现在可能注意到更多的是，最小的孩子和下一个孩子之间存在着显著的年龄差距。所以有些人，你知道的，他们的父母很早就生完孩子了，然后他们又意外地迎来了另一个宝宝，或者他们稍后决定，好吧，感觉我们的家庭还不够完整。感觉好像我们少了一个人，他们选择在很久很久以后再生一个孩子。在这种情况下，最小的孩子可能会表现出独生子女的性格，因为，你知道的，我听说过甚至有15、20年的年龄差距。现在这是可能的。
So with all of that in mind, we can see that being the youngest is quite a complex experience. How do we overcome some of the challenges? How do we embrace the strengths as well as the difficulties? I think talking about the first point that I kind of made way up the top of this episode, which was infantilization, being treated like you're incapable or like you are a child. even when you become an adult, I think what really needs to happen is at some point you have to make a very forceful assertion of your independence.
所以考虑到所有这些，我们可以看到作为老幺是一种相当复杂的体验。我们如何克服一些挑战？我们如何拥抱优势以及困难？我认为谈到我在本集开头提出的第一个观点，也就是幼稚化，被当作没有能力的人或小孩子对待。即使你已经成年，我认为真正需要发生的是，在某个时刻，你必须非常坚定地宣称你的独立性。
And whether that is through having a conversation with your family or moving somewhere like far away or doing something that really says like, I'm my own person, most youngest children will find that at some point they need to address this ongoing sense in their family that they need to be protected. They need to be taken care of. It is actually totally okay to say to your family, hey, you got me wrong. Like, yep, I understand that that is the personality or the person that you thought I was. I'm not that person anymore. And this is who I am.
不管是通过和家人对话，还是搬到一个遥远的地方，或者做一些真正表明我是个独立个体的事情，大多数老幺都会发现在某个时刻他们需要解决家族中这种持续存在的认为他们需要被保护的看法。他们需要被照顾。实际上，对家人说，嘿，你们误解我了，这完全没问题。比如，是的，我理解那是你们认为的我曾经的性格或那种人。我不再是那种人了。这就是现在的我。
I'm someone who is independent. I am someone who is adventurous and who can take care of myself. I want you to treat me that way. Like that's actually totally, totally okay. I think also sometimes there is a point of separation that is needed. A separation between the parents or even your siblings, whether it's through solo traveling, whether it is through moving away, whether it is just through spending a little bit less time with them. A lot of youngest children that I've spoken to or that I've heard speak about this in interviews have been like,
我是个独立的人。我是个有冒险精神且能照顾自己的人。我希望你们这样对待我。这其实真的真的完全没问题。我认为有时也需要有一个分离的时刻。与父母甚至兄弟姐妹的分离，无论是通过独自旅行，无论是通过搬走，还是仅仅通过减少和他们在一起的时间。我聊过的许多老幺，或者听到他们在采访中谈到这一点的老幺都曾表示，
that was the real thing that helped me break out of like the stereotype that my own family was kind of perpetrating. The next big thing that I think we need to address is the sense of competition and comparison. Oof, that's a hard one. And it's not like it's comparison with a random stranger on the internet. Like, you can't really say to yourself, oh, there's gaps in that narrative because the chances are is that you know what's happening with your eldest and older siblings. That's what makes the comparison sting even more is that they are such a close counterpart to you.
那才是真正帮助我打破自己家庭所强化的刻板印象的关键。我认为我们需要解决的下一个重大问题是竞争感和比较感。哇，这真是一个难题。而且这并不像是与互联网上随机陌生人的比较。因为你不能真的对自己说，哦，那个叙事有漏洞，因为很有可能你很清楚你的哥哥姐姐们在发生什么。正是这一点让这种比较更加刺痛，因为他们是你如此亲密的对照物。
what I say to this is this. What I say to this is this. This is what I want to say about it. Like I said, it can feel like there is this constant marker, like ahead of you that you can never catch up to because of your age. I want you to really, really sit and reflect on what it is you're chasing and what is this end goal that you're working towards. Because when you really start to think about it, what you're really chasing is someone else's journey, but also it's like this race to an imaginary finish line. And the imaginary finish line is like the end of your life.
我想对此说的是这个。我想对此说的是这个。这就是我想说的。就像我说的，会觉得前方总有这样一个标记，因为你的年龄，你永远追不上。我希望你真正、真正地坐下来，反思你究竟在追逐什么，你正在努力实现的终极目标是什么。因为当你真正开始思考时，你真正追逐的其实是别人的旅程，但这就像是一场通往虚构终点线的比赛。而虚构的终点线就像是你生命的终结。
So it's okay to take things a little bit slower and just remember that like it's not about timelines. It's not about what other people are doing. This is really like all you have. Like your journey and your life is all you have. And you are totally entitled to figure it out as you go along to take your time to do things that are different. regardless of, you know, if your whole family is very academic and you decide you want to go do something else.
所以放慢一点节奏是没问题的，只需记住这与时间表无关。这与其他人正在做的事情无关。这真的是你拥有的全部。你的旅程和你的生活就是你拥有的全部。你有权在摸索中搞清楚它，花时间去做不同的事情。不管，你知道的，如果你的整个家族都很有学术造诣而你决定去做别的事情。
Like that's okay if your whole family are creatives and you've decided you want to be an accountant. Like that's also okay. You're allowed to assert your own preferences for your life and follow them deeply and commit to them deeply even if there is this person ahead of you who you think that you should be like. Like they're doing, that's their journey. That's their experience. don't let their experience overshadow the one that you want to have as well. My final reflection is that, you know, youngest children face a lot of unique challenges. They also have a lot of gifts.
这没关系，如果你的全家都是创意工作者而你决定成为一名会计。这也完全没准。你可以坚持自己对生活的偏好，并深深地追随它们，坚定地致力于它们，即使你前面有一个你认为自己应该成为的人。他们的所作所为，那是他们的旅程。那是他们的经历。不要让他们的经历掩盖了你也想拥有的经历。我的最后感想是，你知道，最小的孩子面临着许多独特的挑战。他们也有很多天赋。
How can you use that to your advantage? What were the positives that you heard in this episode that you can say, wow, like, I have this ability more than some other people that I would know to be someone who sees risk differently, be someone who is okay with challenging the rules, be someone who thinks outside the box, who is outgoing. Like those are huge advantages. Take those advantages and do with them whatever it is you wish. Like that is you.
你如何利用这一点来发挥你的优势？你在本集听到了哪些积极的方面，你可以说，哇，比如，比起我认识的一些其他人，我更具备这种能力，能够以不同的方式看待风险，能够坦然挑战规则，能够跳出框架思考，性格外向。这些都是巨大的优势。抓住这些优势，去做你希望做的任何事情。那才是真正的你。
You have this beautiful personality. You are probably a wonderful person. Honestly, I have such a soft spot for youngest children. So let's just, yeah, I just think they're amazing. Like, they're some of my favorite people to be friends with. and I love them very, very much. So if you're a youngest child, yeah, big claps for you. I think I probably would really get along with you.
你拥有这样美好的个性。你很可能是一个非常好的人。老实说，我对最小的孩子有一种特别的偏爱。所以让我们，是的，我只是觉得他们太棒了。比如，他们是我最喜欢与之交朋友的人之一。我非常非常喜欢他们。所以如果你是家里最小的孩子，是的，为你疯狂鼓掌。我想我可能真的很合你的胃口。
That's what history has told me. And I want to know if this resonates with you. So this is kind of like my own research. Like, is this accurate? Looking at your own life, do you find yourself reflected in this analysis? Or do you think you're someone who is very, very different? And if you are, if you think you're someone who's very, very different, I want to hear from you just as much as the people who say like, this is really spot on for me because, you know, I'm constantly questioning this theory as well and I want to know anecdotally, like, whether it applies. So I'd love to hear from you. If there's anything else that you think stands out with you and your youngest child friends, let me know that as well. And I hope you just enjoyed this episode. I hope you learned something. Make sure to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening. Drop a comment down below if you're a youngest child and what you have learned from this episode or what resonates with you.
这就是历史告诉我的情况。我想知道这是否能引起你的共鸣。所以这有点像我自己的研究。这准确吗？审视你自己的生活，你发现自己在这个分析中得到了映射吗？还是你认为自己是一个非常非常不同的人？如果你是，如果你认为自己是一个非常非常不同的人，我想听听你的声音，就像那些说“这真的很切中我”的人一样，因为，你知道，我也在不断质疑这个理论，我想通过轶事了解它是否适用。所以我很想听到你的反馈。如果你觉得你和你最小的孩子朋友们身上还有其他什么突出的地方，也请告诉我。我希望你喜欢这一集。希望你学到了一些东西。记得在苹果播客、Spotify或你收听的任何地方留下五星评价。如果你是最小的孩子，请在下方留言，分享你从这一集中学到了什么，或者什么引起了你的共鸣。
And we'll be back next week with another episode. Until then, stay safe. Stay kind. Be gentle to yourself. And we will talk soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
我们下周将带着另一集回归。在此之前，请注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会交谈。在“回顾过去”播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和说是个大时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试理清我们是如何与朋友、喜剧同行和最喜欢的作家一起幸存下来的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听“艰难学习”，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“艰难学习”。2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“受困之爱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“受困之爱”播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健康和体能的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。
That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
那是IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想逃脱。他将得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女友。收听“女友们”。
Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝，在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证人类制作本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。